that's like the weirdest thing I've ever
seen fire cupping therapy is an ancient
practice that uses localized pressure to
promote healing and to reduce pain in
the body is it gonna burn at all like
you set the cup on fire I light a piece
of cotton ball on fire and I stick it
into the cup to combust the oxygen but
it doesn't burn so it fire is literally
touching you might feel the heat from
the rim of the glass cup but that's
about it
I've seen people after they've gotten
cupping and they have these big circles
on their back and it looks kind of
bruised you can think of it almost like
a hickey so the it's the breaking of the
blood capillaries how much squealing do
you usually hear when you perform this
on people rarely rarely squeals unless
you want the cuffs super-strong I mean
if we were looking to experience pain we
could do oh I'm excited
Friday I'm really excited about getting
this done Sonya was saying about how
it's like a reverse massage so I think
it's gonna be really cool so first I
douse a cotton ball alcohol
right on fire get a torch you stick the
fire inside of the glass it doesn't hurt
though guys it's interesting cuz she
says it doesn't hurt but it looks like
it hurt it looks like there's a giant
pimples yeah once she starts moving the
cups and makes me squirm whoa
Macy how does that feel when she's
gliding like that in your back it feels
really good it feels like a massage she
can't move so her head is just
completely still so just our eyeballs
moving around really like that same for
Clockwork Orange
[Music]
guys it felt really good now I feel so
loose and good and I wish I could go
home and take a nap instead of having to
go back to work which is what I have to
do right now actually the oil looks
great I'm really excited for the oil it
looks like the best part mixed with her
voice I feel like I'll fall asleep right
there the tattoo in your back when it
bubbles up it turns into a totally
different picture she's making art over
here guys
it's crazy like if I have like a toilet
plunger on my back that's what this
feels like you been a toilet plunger on
your back before you don't know my life
Ryan so there's certain way you have to
take the cuffs off yep they're mobile
now do you ever do this with a giant cup
like a fishbowl I've used shot glasses
or even wine glasses and like if I'm at
someone's house that's just we party
trick it is a great party trick I also
feel like it like intensifies her touch
like now it's like she's got those
tranquilizer fingers
putting you to sleep Jesus hands yeah
things like body scare me like needles
like going into skin like visceral
things like that scare me so really he's
just like the world isn't ready to see
my p90x back every time like sugar mint
you ready
it's Brady's over V let's go that is so
straight hey that was I - oh man my bag
is so tight is it uncomfortably tight Oh
yours looks super red like I don't like
it's a meter or so oh my god you're so
good
how did you guys not react as strongly
as I just did cuz that was some crazy
stuff that just happened back there yeah
this look like somebody made out
intensely with your back and that's all
I wanted so oh really
oh yeah and then now she's just like
just piercing the blood everywhere
that's exactly correct I could do my
blood dispersing I wanna ball this
moment and living it forever it just
kind of takes the words out of your
mouth you know like I'm just very serene
I'm at peace right now it's tingling
with just enjoyment so I can't really
tell if it's in pain but I feel right
now
it felt really good it did feel a lot
like Sonia was saying like a reverse
massage after she'd done the cuffing and
then she was just touching like where
the cuffs were like I guess like a
little circle like it's like uh-huh yes
it was a treacherous journey but in the
end I think we ended up what we wanted
to be
[Music]
you